plot the ordered pair 6 comma negative 8
into the coordinate plane so this is the
coordinate plane right over here the
horizontal axis here this is the x axis
the vertical axis here is the y axis and
the convention when we give it get a
coordinate when again we get an ordered
pair like this is that the first
coordinate is the x coordinate and the
second coordinate is the y coordinate so
they're telling us that we have an x
coordinate of 6 x coordinate of 6 that
means we count up 6 on the x axis so
let's count up 1 I can even write down 1
and then we have 2 that's right there
then we have 3 then we have 4 then we
have 5 and then we have moved up we've
moved up 6 along the x axis we started
at the origin at 0 0 that's the origin
and we moved 6 to the right that's this
part right over here now our y
coordinate is negative 8 that means we
move down 8 in the vertical direction so
we can see it right over here so this
right here I'll just do that every 2 so
this is down 1 this right here is
negative 2 negative 3 this right here is
negative 4 negative 5 negative 6
negative 7 negative 8 so we move to the
right 6 and then we move down 8 we move
to the right 6 and then we move down 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 & 8 and we are right over
there so that is the point 6 6 negative
8 you can also look at it this way the x
coordinate is 6 so you move 6 there and
so we're going to be along this line
right over here and then you can go and
then the y coordinate is negative 8 so
you go down to negative 8 and say we're
going to be along this line over here
and the place that they intersect is
this coordinate the easiest way I'd like
to think of it move six to the right
move along the x axis and then move
along in the vertical direction along
the y axis so you go down 8